[Music]
a woman in houston is currently in shock
after an eyebrow microblading session
gone wrong like medical shock
or like oh my god wasn't so ugly like
typical female hysteria
victorian hysteria so not not medical
shock non-medical purely emotional
eyebrow so she like [ __ ] up and the
eyebrows like like
two inches above they gave her a
permanent surprise look
kind of like that shocked look
you guys know what what microwaving is
right yeah they do like the it looks
like
it looks like little hair yeah but it's
just like it looks real though yeah it
looks it just makes it darker right yeah
it looks amazing sometimes why do they
like their eyebrows so dark
that's kind of a slippery slope
eyebrows no i know some girls that like
they have to diet people my family
they have regular looking eyebrows but
then they go get this done and their
eyebrows look thicker and like darker
and in my head i can't help but to think
like why'd you do that because of cara
delevingne that's why
yeah i think they like it no it's you
know how it goes like when the trend
changes that's what's a little scary
about tattooing your makeup
yeah because like maybe in 10 years it
won't be cool i think it wears off after
a few years like heavily i don't think
it's like 10-year permanent
it should be you know it should be
she can learn the lesson ladies
remember didn't didn't a lot of guys
used to pluck their eyebrows back in the
early 2000s
i did that [ __ ] yeah no more of that
what do you mean used to i got called
gay so much back then when you used to
you we're not supposed to do that i
don't do that but
i just plucked this part right here so
here she is before
all right look eyebrows it doesn't seem
like she needs them her eyebrows look
pretty why does she need to have them
darker really you think those look
perfect those are uh makeup
i mean they're probably got a little bit
of makeup or like oh yeah i got a little
makeup yeah
like filled in with eyeliner or
something but that ain't nothing
compared to these daddies
holy [ __ ] did a japanese person do them
her lips look crazy too
that looks like i'm from back in there
one of those geishas
i believe it was a uh
a micro she looks like she's having an
allergic reaction on her lips too did
they do her lips too
no they did not even symmetrical the
eyebrows don't even look the same on
both sides yeah
i didn't imagine paying money for that
who did this who so dude they suck how
long does that usually last uh long
enough it will it's yeah it lasts too
long that she's now seeking corrective
uh surgery to like take it off oh man
she does look surprised might be able to
get it lasered off and then but would it
laser off the hair follicles too and
then completely be gone yeah it's
probably gonna look like when you remove
a tattoo yeah but like
does the hair get removed too
permanently what did she go to well
there's no hair on the part where they
went over anyways i went to anita's
micro bleeding yeah it's off of sodo
that's not that's not microblading
that's a macroblading [ __ ] right there's
a [ __ ] thick-ass line i mean was it
done by like a seven-year-old trainee
because like
it's like someone just started what the
[ __ ] dude
i i wanna think that it was one of those
like discount ones where you're like get
what you pay for you get what you pay
for
if i this is gonna sound mean but maybe
not if i was the attorney for the
defendant
i would ask her
didn't you feel
like the blading part go too high but
you let it go not just on one eyebrow
but on the other eyebrow as well because
why didn't you stop it yeah you're like
ah why is it why is it touch there why
is it feeling good why is it hitting my
hairline
oh we're trying to combine them we're
trying to that's my hairline bro and
then do you think anita was like no
trust me don't worry it'll look good you
know how um you know how with whip
[ __ ] sounds sexist but you know with
women like there's a lot of times where
a girl will go
like she cut my hair too short and
they're just like crying and you're like
why didn't you [ __ ] feel that it was
like she was taking too much it's like a
thing where like out of politeness
sometimes they don't want to like yeah
you don't want to stop the person and go
wait are you doing it right you know
because it's kind of rude yeah i heard
the hair thing is because it shrinks
so you know when the hair is long
because it has its own weight right so
when they when they spray it with water
it's completely straight and then so
they go okay cool so here's the shoulder
and if they're not experienced they'll
cut exactly at the shoulder instead of
down here because once you cut it and
then the hair dries then it goes up
it's not wet anymore that's a pro tip
right there i did not know they're
supposed to like cut if they say i
wanted this you're supposed to give it a
little bit because you're wetting it and
where'd you load this from
geocomplaining a lot
well because that's something if you
guys have ever dated someone at some
point you're going to hear them complain
that someone did their hair too short
yeah or too wrong many times or [ __ ] the
bangs up yeah but you know like how does
it get to that point where you wait till
the shrinkage dude that's what it is i
think that's the only explanation
because this girl she should have known
when they were touching above where her
normal eyebrows i mean look how far
above that is that's a whole true man
extra eyebrow up that's just they don't
even look the same i just love that here
i love how thick those lines are well
here's a here's a dead giveaway line
that you don't want to hear this is what
the person said at the end of the
session she looked and told me not to
freak out oh oh my god
don't please don't freak out and then
wouldn't that person know too oh this is
too far i think it's one of those things
where like you know when the first time
you learn how to fade you go too high
and then you go too high and you go too
high trying to correct it
it might have been that i feel like it's
someone that's just learned how to do
this and then they're just trying to
correct it by going more into it and
it's like it's like have you ever done
art with just a pen before
and then there's parts where you're
shading and you're like
[ __ ] bro and then you keep shading and
you're like now the whole thing's just
black
we've gone too far
so she thought she um the actual
microblader
actually said i might have gone too high
with the hair stroke but it's fine
because i'm gonna order a remover to
correct it like that it's that easy
that's how it works it wasn't apparently
because
yeah
and she said
and then she also said it'll look better
once the swelling goes down
yeah it doesn't change the fact that
it's up here right it doesn't change the
fact that it's like sharpied in bro what
the [ __ ] i think it's like dark as [ __ ]
it's like microblading it's supposed to
be like look like hairs yeah it's
supposed to have micro blades yeah i've
seen it before it looks good when it's
done right yeah actually just looks like
a tattoo
yeah like for all you guys with
significant others
if your woman came home i slap her in
the face
just to fix it you know that is a scary
like what would you like what would you
oh and then like worse yeah this is the
even worse thought
you got home early and you went to bed
early and you didn't see her till you
woke up in the morning i'm screaming
is that right
yeah and then she forgot it was like hey
good morning
you throw up on her
sorry man [ __ ] i would feel pretty sad
because i know that she would also be
upset i feel sad for myself
yeah cuz you're the one that has to look
at her i'm wearing sunglasses the rest
of the day
and the sunglasses don't even her
sunglasses can't cover it
she's got to get the visor glasses
okay at what point like in the in the
dating scheme like a month two months
three months if you were dating her
would you just be like okay we're just
going to break up
would that happen yeah
are we dating and then she got this done
or beforehand she got this done already
no like you're like you're dating and
let's say like in a month and then she
comes like this like you'd be like ah
yeah i can't see you anymore but you
know i imagine if you're married it's
like
a day or a week day or week yeah what
where where would your threshold be to
be like how much do you like this person
yeah that's that i think that's where it
comes in the timeline oh yeah you know
like a month in how fixable is how much
is this going to cost
i'm calling the [ __ ] social services
on that [ __ ]
check this out i've been with this girl
for so long all right she needs help
like come on not a child you can't just
pawn her off i was like just come over
here she needs help
look at her eyes dude the crazy thing is
if you really look at it there's
absolutely no portion of it that looks
like it could have been good like not
even the parts that are correctly there
like look how uneven it is yeah or even
how
how low this part is
right it's like all of it's bad
that looks like it's fresh and then the
the this is like it's healing because
it's like this is like she's still
crying she's like oh my god and then
this one she's like all right next day
how bad that is it also doesn't help
that her face is like
like what if that's her default like
look too it's like oh you've got to
match the brow to the person imagine she
was muslim and she had that thing on and
just all the time just angry
oh no
that's true
yeah where was this at
this was in westminster
houston
where everything's bigger
just like the eyebrows she paid 340
bucks for this god what's the normal
price for it 300 300 for like 500. oh
it's a good deal see what the average
price is for something it can kind of
get pricey but i kind of would like to
look at it like a tattoo like
just
it's gonna be on you forever but yeah
you better pay for a good average cost
of microblading in los angeles is 675
dollars so she got a discount click 19
more rows and see if houston comes up
okay or maybe yeah google houston
because maybe they might be cheaper
still still though like i think 300 is
like not a lot of money for that yeah
570 is the average houston wow so she
got a basically she got a fifty percent
she's a little pick and save one
she's probably got a group she might got
groupon yeah for sure that's what i'm
saying she probably got someone that's
like i'm learning and i need to
experience you know how you can go to
the community college and get free
yeah
you can go to cerritos college and get a
free haircut from the training yeah but
the only rules you can you can't say
nothing you can't get mad you can't you
can't even react yeah but the hair will
grow back uh
yeah i know
eyebrows are forever yeah so your third
date with the girl and she comes like
that well here's a good uh what did you
do
i mean it's our body dope so check it
out look at these price comparisons for
these two jobs 700 at the top 210 at the
bottom
oh yeah look see the one up top looks
good the one at the bottom looks like an
ant trail
the the one at the bottom the hair is
growing in opposite directions it's the
great the grains like
sorry i had it scrolled wrong there you
go
see the top one it's like it grows in a
natural direction that bottom one
they're growing in all kinds of
directions disgusting i like that the
bottom one looks like you need to like
pluck it like adjust it it's like they
tattooed in like good and they're so
close together about to touch the bottom
one she was lost in the wilderness for
like a month and in the top one she's
like ready to go out with her friends
the bottom one looks like a madame
tussad version of this yeah
i'd like to free uh microblading for a
mustache to kind of grow on my skin yeah
i'll do it with you for a full
manchester if you show up with a [ __ ]
microblade in monday i know a place for
270 dollars
i need the fibers to be all over the
place
you